the FBI is investigating a potential
hate crime in American University in
Washington students found several
bananas Monday hanging from small ropes
Todd Lake nooses racist racist messages
were written on the bananas campus
police released two surveillance videos
Tuesday of a possible suspect a thousand
dollar reward is being offered for
information leading to the person chip
Reid is outside the American University
campus in Washington where students are
on edge chip good morning
well good morning this is not the first
racist incident here at American
University in September white two
students were accused of throwing a
banana at one black student and leaving
a rotten banana in the dorm room of
another this latest incident happened on
the same day that a black woman became
student body president a first for this
university surveillance video shows a
person dressed in black early Monday
morning approaching two of the locations
where the racist messages were placed
the bananas had the words harambe bait
and AKA free written on them police
believe they referenced Alpha Kappa
Alpha the predominantly black sorority
where the new student body president
Taylor dumps in' is a member hate and
racism and bigotry have no place on this
campus and that's not we want here on
this university not as a student not a
student government president and on
behalf of the AU community that is not
what we need here and this is not what
we need anywhere in this country Terry
Flenory is vice president of
communications at the University we made
some direct outreach to the students who
are members of Alpha Kappa Alpha and
immediately worked to identify what we
could do to support them and make them
feel safe but some don't think it's
enough on Tuesday students marched
across campus in protest and walked out
of a town hall meeting yeah it's all
really frustrating Danyelle Jermaine is
the social media chair for the black
students Alliance he saw a lot of great
action from students that wasn't met by
great action from administration
messages of hate are not isolated to
American University according to the
latest report from the federal office
for civil rights the number of
complaints involving racial harassment
and post-secondary education more than
doubled over seven years from
96 and 2009 to 198 in 2016 Thompson says
communication is key to prevent racism
on campus I just really want to
encourage the student body members of
our community to really focus on
community building and communicating
with one another about our feelings and
on topics that we don't always feel
comfortable with talking about like race
college campuses across the nation are
seeing similar hate incidents at the
University of Maryland last week a noose
was found inside a fraternity house and
at the University of Denver this week
swastikas were carved into cars near a
Jewish student organization Nora it's
outrageous I'm glad that American
University is taking action thanks Jeff